الديمقراطيون يحتفظون بالسيطره على مجلس
الشيوخ بعد فوز كاترين ماستو بالمقعد عن
ولايه نيفادا
[موسيقى]
الجيش الاوكرانيه
روسيا بمحاولته اذلال شعبه عبر تدمير
البنيه التحتيه
تظاهرات الليليه في عدد من المدن
الايرانيه لا سيما طهران وفارس و شيراز
هتفت بمجملها ضد النظام
[موسيقى]
اوقاتكم نشره اخباريه من العربيه اهلا بكم
نبدا باخر مستجدات الانتخابات النصفيه
واخر تطورات النتائج
[موسيقى]
في اخر تطورات النتائج النصفيه الامريكيه
احتفظت الديمقراطيه كاترين ماستو بمقعد
بمقعدها بمجلس الشيوخ عن ولايه نيفادا بعد
فوزها على الجمهوري ادم
باعاده انتخابها يرتفع عدد الديمقراطيين
المنتخبين في مجلس الشيوخ الى 50 من اصل
100 ما يسمح للحزب الديمقراطي بالسيطره
على المجلس باعتبار ان الصوت المرجح يعود
الى نائبه رئيس
ولم تعد انتخابات الاعاده المنتظره في
مطلع ديسمبر في جورجيا تحدث فرقا في
النتيجه
في مجلس النواب لا تزال عمليات الفرز
مستمره في حينا يبدو ان الجمهوريين اقرب
للسيطره ولو باغلبيه بسيطه ويفصلهم عن ذلك
سبعه مقاعد فقط فمن اصل 218 مقعدا وهو
الرقم المطلوب للفوز حصل الجمهوريون حتى
الان على 2011 مقعدا فيما حصل
الديمقراطيون على 200 و خمسه مقاعد
منا واشنطن مراسل العربيه حسين الطود حسين
اهلا بك قراءه في هذه النتائج حتى الان في
الولايات المتحده
الديمقراطيون واخيرا نستطيع ان اقول انهم
تنفسوا الصعداء بهذا الفوز في نيفادا في
الحقيقه هم قبلوا حسنا في نيفادا فاضافه
الى الاحتفاظ بمقعد مجلس الشيوخ ومحفظه
ايضا على مستوى مجلس النواب ثلاثه مقاعد
وكما انه
انفازعوا ايضا منصب سكرتير قال الولايه
ولكن الخساره الوحيده التي من فيها في
نيفادا هي خساره منصب الحاكم الذي فاز به
جوله برده الجمهوري الان بهذا الفوز اما
الديمقراطيون همم اذا عملتهم على
السيطراتهم على مجلس الشيوخ وكما تفضلت في
الخبر لم يعد لمعركه جورجيا همم لم تعد
جورج ساحه حسن في هذه الانتخابات هي دوره
اعاده عاديه اذا تمكنت ديمقراطيون من
الفوز بها من عبر مرشحهم رافاييل وناق
سيزيدون اا اغلبيتهم ولكن اذا فاز بها
الجمهوريون ستبقى ستعود الامور الى ما
كانت عليه قبل الانتخابات التشديد النصفي
اي 50 50 مع صوت كما حارس نائبه الرئيس
قال همم لصالح الديمقراطيين همم هذا هو
بشكل عام طبعا نحن نتوقع منذ ان تتزايد
حده الجدل داخل الحز بالجمهوري حول
مسؤوليه عدم حصول اولا هذه الموجه الحمراء
التي كنا نتوقعها وكان يتوقعها المحللون
ايضا همم عدم تمكن الجمهوريين من تزاع
السيطره على المجلس الشيوخ على عكس تنبؤات
معظم الاستطلاعات الرئيس خاصه منذ بدايه
شهر نوفمبر التي رجحت كفه الجمهوريين منها
مثلا
الذي الذي اعطى همم افضليه للجمهوريه
للاحتفاظ
او للسيطره على مجلس الشيوخ همم طبعا همم
البعض من الجمهوريين يرفض القاء اللوم على
شخص واحد في اشاره الى دونالد ترامب كما
قال ركس كود العضو الجمهوري في مجلس
الشيوخ ولكن الكثير من المحللين
الجمهوريين يقولون ان ترامب هو المسؤول
بسبب ترشيحاته التي اختار بها مرشحين ليس
لديهم خبره كافيه لخوض غمار هذه
الانتخابات طبعا اضافه الى مواضيع الدم
مثل الموضوع الاجهاض الذي ايضا همم حشد
همم
المستقلين ولا سيما من النساء يصوتوا
الجمهوريه
والدوري الذي لاعبه ايضا الرئيس
الاخيره كلها عوامل لعب ضدهم ولكن ما زلنا
نسمع من بعض الجمهوريين
يقول ان ال ال المشكله كانت في عدم حث
يعني بالتاكيد هذا ما سيدفعنا ايضا الى
انتظار اليومين القادمين واعلان الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب عن نيتها
لخوض الانتخابات ام لا شكرا جزيلا حتى
الان حسين الطوده مراسل العربيه من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
في مستجدات الحرب في اوكرانيا اعلن الرئيس
الاوكرانيين افراديميراز الانسكيان الجيش
الاوكراني تمكن من استعاده السيطره على
اكثر من 60% من منطقه خيرسون وان الشرطه
تتخذ الاجراءات اللازمه لتحقيق الاستقرار
في المنطقه
على اكثر من 60 مستوطنه في منطقه خيرسون
وبدات الشرطه في اتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه
لتحقيق الاستقرار في المنطقه خبراء
المتفجرات لدينا لديهم الكثير من العمل في
كل مكان في المنطقه المحرره ولقد تمت
ازاله ما يقرب من 2000 ماده متفجره
دمر المحتلون جميع البناء التحتيه الحيويه
بما فيها قطاع الاتصالات وامدادات المياه
والتدفئه والك
يلا يلا
[موسيقى]
امرت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بدفعه اضافيه
من صواريخ تسيركون المتطوره التي تفوق
سرعتها سرعه الصوت حسب وكاله تاسست وقال
مصدر عسكري ان العقد المبرم في هذا الخريف
هو الثاني الذي يتم توقيعه
وهو ثاني من نوعه ويشمل عشرات الصواريخ
وينبغي ان يكتمل في عام 2023 يذكر ان
تجارب حال الصاروخ تمت باستخدام هي فرقه
الاسطوره الشماليه ادميرال جورج كوبا في
عام 2021 وفي وقت سابق بدات روسيا
الاختبارات الاولى للسلاح من حامله تحت
البحر وهي الغواصه التي تعمل بطاقه
النوويه صفره
في ايران انطلقت تظاهرات الليليه في عدد
من المدن الايرانيه لا سيما طهران فارس
شيراز هتفت بمجملها ضد النظام وحملت شعار
الموت للديكتاتور
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
من بعيد
بس قلبي قرود براويزه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذه النشره مستمره ونتابع فيها ايضا
اصطدامه طائره ب 17 مع طائره اخرى في عرض
جوي في دالاس
حياكم الله تلقى ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان اتصالا هاتفيا من الرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون جرى خلاله بحث
سبل تعزيز العلاقات الثنائيه بين البلدين
في اطار الشراكه الاستراتيجيه بينهما
واستعرض الجانبان ابرز القضايا والمسجدات
الاقليميه والدوليه والجهود المبذوله
تجاهها لتعزيز الامن والاستقرار وثمنا ولي
العهد السعودي دعم فرنسا للامن والاستقرار
في المنطقه ورفضها للتهديدات التي تدخل
باستقرار المنطقه
قال وزير الاعلام اليمنيين معمر الارياني
ان جماعه الحوثي انشات شبكات لتجاره
المخدرات باشراف في قيادات بارزه في
الجماعه لاغراق اليمن بهذه الاثار واكد
الارياني انه تم ضبط عدد من السفن
والبحاره الايرانيين
المتورطين بتهريب المخدرات وان النظام
الايراني يواصلوا اغراق الاغراض اليمنيه
بشحنات الاسلحه والمخدرات واشار الارياني
الى ان ميليشيا الحوثي انشات هذه الشبكات
لتمويل انشطتها التخريبيه وطلب موقف واضح
من المجتمع طالب بموقف واضح من المجتمع
الدولي ضد التدخلات الايرانيه في اليمن
في اليوم الثاني لجلسات مبادره السعوديه
الخضراء في قمه شرم الشيخ للمناخ تعرفها
العديد من المشاركين في جلسات الحوار على
الجهود الحديثه للمملكه وفقه رؤيه جديده
لمستقبل الطاقه النظيفه وجهودها المتنوعه
للوصول الى الحياد الصفري
للانبعاثات الكربونيه احمد عثمان
البوابه المخصصه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
والاهتمام بالشباب وهذا شيء جيد للغايه
لان المناخ والاستدامه سيكونان من اجل
مستقبلهم
خبراء من الشرق والغرب حرص ايضا على
التجول داخل القاعه للتعرف على المشاريع
والمبادرات المتنوعه التي تسعى لتحقيق ما
تطرحه المبادره كثيرون ابدو اعجابهم في
القدره على طرح هذا الكم من الافكار
والمشاريع في شتى انواع التغير المناخي من
خلال عام واحد فقط
في العمل بين الحكومه والقطاع الخاص هناك
تعاون واضح بين اشخاص يريدون العمل معا
لهدف مشترك ومن المنتظر ان تستمر نسخه
الثانيه من مبادره السعوديه الخضراء حتى
نهايه كوب 27 في الثامن عشر من الشهر
الحالي
وستتوقعتهم بان تكون هذه المبادره وما
تطرحه من تعهدادات الرسميه وافكار ومشاريع
تشكلان احد اهم الملامح اللي عالم الطاقه
الجديده للعقود المقبله احمد عثمان
العربيه شرم الشيخ
زعماء ودبلوماسي والعالم المعركه ضد
الاحتباس الحراري على انها معركه من اجل
بقاء الانسان خلال اجتماعهم في قمه المناخ
في كوب 27
بمصر وتحدث الرسائل الصارخه نداء عاجلا
لمعرفه كيفيه تجنب اسوا تغير مناخي
[موسيقى]
هل الحرب الاوكرانيه طغت على قمه الاسيان
التي انطلقت في كمبوديا ماذا فعل المتحده
للتحذير من الانقسامات في القمه بايدينا
الحاضر للقمه ركز على تداعيات الحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا والتوتر المرتبط
بتهديدات كوريا الشماليه
تحضيرات ودعوات من خطر انقسام المحتمل على
العالم باسره تبدا بها قمه اسيا اعمالها
حيث يلتقي قاده دول الرابطه لاول مره منذ
سنوات وجها لوجه في محاوله ربما لمعالجه
ازمه الولاءات بين الصين وروسيا واشنطن
اداره البيضه اعتمدت وفقه مراقبين
استراتيجيه تخيير دول اسيا بينها وبين
بكين ولتحقيق المراد بتحجيم النفود الصيني
المتزايده في منطقه اسيا والمحيطين تسعى
الاداره الامريكيه الى تعزيز تعاون مع دول
العشره الاعضاء في رابطه اسيا الامر دفع
ببيض المشاركه في القمه التي تعاقد سنويا
والتي غاب عنها سلفه ترامب منذ عام 2017
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه والتوتر بين
واشنطن والصين وازمه كوريا الشماليه ضغط
على قمه الاسيان التي تبحث وقضايا
اقتصاديه فكانها مكانا الاجتماعات
الامريكيه يابانيه كوريه جنوبيه بحثت
بتهديدات كوريا الشماليه الصاروخيه
والنوويه وتعاونها مع روسيا بعد اسيان
ستنتقل الانظار الى جزيره بالي اندونيسيه
الاسبوع المقبل لقمه مجموعه العشرين والتي
ستكون فيها الحرب الاوكرانيه والعلاقات مع
روسيا على راس الاجنده الرئيس الاندلسي
مصممون على انجاحها ولتحقيق هدفه وجد نفسه
مجبرا على القيام برحله غير سهله اليكيه
حيث سلمت دعوه حضور القمه الى نظره
الاوكراني بشكل شخص لينطلق بعدها الى
موسكو حاملا دعوه مماثله الى الرئيس بوتين
في جزيره بالي لم يكتب اللقاء بين بيض
وبوتين لكنه انذار المراقبين ستتعلقه هناك
حيث سيجمع لقاء بين بيض والرئيس الصيني
يتوقع ان يبحث التنافس الاقتصادي وطلب
امريكي من الصين لاستخدام نفوتها على
روسيا
تراجعي في اوكرانيا حنان المصري العربيه
رحبت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بالتزام
طرفي اتفاق السلامي في اثيوبيا بيسال
المساعدات الانسانيه دون عوائق الى اقليم
والمناطق المتضرره في اقليم اي عفار
وامهره وطلب بيان الخارجيه الامريكيه
الطرفين باحترامي وقف الاعمال للعدائيه
وتسريع استعاده الخدمات الاساسيه في كافه
انحاء الشماليه اثيوبيا كما دعت الخارجيه
الامريكيه الى بدء التحقيق والمحاسبه بشان
انتهاكاته حقوق الانسان في شمال البلاد
اعلن الملياردير الى الماسكا في تغريده له
وعوده تويتر بلو لتوثيق على الحساب
بالعلامه الزرقاء نهايه الاسبوع المقبل
وكانت تويتر اوقفت مؤقتا اللون الازرق
الذي تم الاعلان عنه مؤخرا بقيمه ثمانيه
دولارات من اجل التحقق من خدمه الاشتراكات
لحسابات وهميه
جورنال في مقال لها الى ان العاملين في
مجال التكنولوجيا يواجهون حرب مواهب في ظل
موجه تسريح شهدتها عده شركات عملاقه
كتويتر ميتا التاني لجا تاني لفصل عدد
كبير من الموظفين اما جوجل فقررت ايقاف
التوظيف حتى اشعار اخر
البطوله او التسريح بالجمله شبح اخر يصيب
هذه المره العاملين في كبرى شركات
التكنولوجيا لمع نجمهم في العصر الرقمي
لكنهم باتو يمرون بمنعطف كبير وسريع
عنوانه الركود الاقتصادي مع ارتفاع
التكاليف وضع في سوق الاعلانات
ليس ذلك فحسب بل ان العاملين في هذا
المجال يواجهون واقعا جديدا تحول فيه
التوظيف في الساحه الرقميه الى حرب مواهب
وفقا عن ولد صحيفه
الامريكيه التي اكدت ان العمل في هذا
العالم الافتراضي مر بفتره حرجه
واستشهدت الصحيفه بما جرى خلال الفتره
الماضيه فلم تكن وحدها منصه تويتر احدثت
عاصفه بتسريحه نصف موظفيها لان مجموعه
ميته الملكه للفيسبوك وانستغرام استغنت
لاول مره في تاريخها عن احد 10,000 خلال
اسبوع
ويضاف اليهما عملاقه محرك البحث جوجل الذي
اغلقه هو الاخر مجال توظيف
وبحسب الصحيفه فان الموظفين العاملين في
هذا القطاع التكنولوجيا اعتاد على مناصب
برواسبه كبيره وحزن اسهم
لكنهم امام هذا الوضع باتو يواجهون
البطاله لاول مره في حياتهم المهنيه الى
جانب تقلص صافي ثرواتهم معا انخفاض قيم
التداول بعد ما شهد هذا القطاع حقبه تطور
ادهشت العالم باسره لعقد من الزمن اذا
اكدت البيانات ان التوظيف في هذا المجال
ارتفع بنسبه 28% في 2022 مقارنه بالعام
السابق لكن موجات التسريح دفعت البعض الى
العمل لساعات طوال خوفا من فقدان عملهم او
سهوله استبدالهم فمن الصوت التوظيف تضج
بالطلبات لا سيما في الشركات الناشئه التي
تستقطب بعض المواهب من الشركات الكبرى
لكنها مع ذلك لن تكون كافيهتا لاستيعاب
جميع الخسائر اسراء الصغير العربيه
ما زالت منصه اف تي اكس ثاني اكبر منصه
تداول العملات المشفره تخضع لتحقيقات
الامريكيه حول شبهاتي تلاعبها بارصده
المتعاملين في عمليات مضاربه ورهانات
خطيره مع اختفاء ما قيمته 8 مليارات دولار
من تلك الارصده وافادت التقارير ان المنصه
شهد التدفقات الخارجيه غامضه بعد التقدم
بطلب الحمايه من الافلام وتتراوح اموال
العملاء بين مليار وملياردولار التي اختفت
من البورصه وفي الوقت نفسه تقدر شركه
البيانات انه تم نقل
473 مليون دولار من اف تي اكس في عمليه
اختراق المشبه بها وان مؤسس البورصه
حول سرا عشره مليارات دولار من اموال
العملاء الى شركه تابعه له
اصطدمت الطائره ب 17 مع طائره اخرى اثناء
معرض دالاس الجوي وذلك خلال العرض الجوي
التذكاري للقوات الجويه فوق المدينه
الديمقراطيون يحتفظون بالسيطره على مجلس
الشيوخ بعد فوز كاترين ماستو بالمقعد عن
ولايه نيفادا
الجيش الامريكيه خيرسون
يتهمروسيا بمحاولته ادلال شعبه عبر تدمير
البنيه التحتيه
تظاهرات الليليه في عدد من المدن
الايرانيه لاسم طهران وفارس وشيراز هتفت
بمجملها ضد النظام
القاكم بعد قليل
[موسيقى]